[Music]
Career and Technical Education is
enjoying a moment governor's talk about
it and education advocates celebrated is
this a passing fad or something more our
recent analysis of media coverage finds
that CTE has been growing steadily in
popularity over the past two decades
since 1998 the number of articles
mentioning CTE has risen more than a
hundredfold and the number of media
mentions has doubled since 2012
attention to CTE now Dwarfs that pay the
education reforms like school vouchers
or personalized learning put in the
context of pop culture press mentions of
CTE rival mentions of celebrities like
Kim Kardashian Steph Curry or Queen
Elizabeth the rise of CTE is part of a
bigger trend the increased attention to
skills training and workforce
preparedness a careful look at how CTE
got here suggests that for better or
worse it's likely to remain a focal
point of education reform in the decade
to come how do you think that America's
schools can best equip students to
succeed after graduation let us know in
our poll also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI